[Music]
welcome everyone we are ready to start
our lecture today and we're going to
talk about end games and only end games
at this class so the first position I
have is this interesting opposite color
end game where you see and
usually if it's the same amount of Pawns
and opposite color Bishops it's should
be a draw
so but uh there are some exceptions and
in this position actually black is going
to be able to win this so here it's very
difficult to do anything for white
because in particular who can tell me
what is the main problem in this
position let's think for a minute think
for a minute so we don't just uh you
know think so we can even understand
what's going on here why you know what
normally this should be a draw but but
why this position black cannot you know
white cannot make a draw here what do
you think here
yes no him
yeah well yeah Sol let Pawn it's a
problem but that's not the main reason
why you cannot draw this you know the
main reason is something else here it's
a huge reason okay
Julian
White's Bishop cannot really move here
but you need to explain this idea
because why it looks like I can just
move yeah Bishop D2 Bishop D3 Bishop B3
why can't he move the bishop this is the
question if he plays for example the
move Bishop to
D2 or Bishop to E3 now what is the
winning move here everybody see
it what is the winning move now Bishop
moves here yes A3 you push the pawn now
if he takes you
push cannot stop it now you see this is
a very unique position because normally
two on two opposite color almost any
position you can draw but here you can't
and if he goes Bishop here you don't
take anymore what do you do p you push
there you go you push the pass Pawn okay
that's what you do
excellent so now in this position white
played King
D2 but you think it's going to be easy
no not easy to win this actually so
let's see if you can find that ideas
here how to win this position okay King
D2 here now black to
move let's try to analyze this position
and find that winning plan
here this is a position played by a
grandm actually long time ago
grandm you know CA want manag to win
this
how which piece we need to improve here
that is the first
question
yes
mhm so let's say you move King to
D4 and
uh King
here King to
E2 now we can probably give him another
check
correct this way we're forcing him to
come here
and this way he's at least blocking his
own
Bishop but now we need a maneuver we
need a good maneuver here to win because
also if our King can get in on C2 that
will be also winning line but here
that's why he goes King D2 if he goes
King F2 loses to King D3 and King here
okay so what to do here
black to
move
Julian
better you could go Bishop H5 but um he
decided to go Bishop E8 okay
Bishop
E8 so King
E2
uh he went yeah he went here here Bishop
here now you go here Bishop B5 check now
if the king doesn't go on D2 your king
will get into C2 so he has to play King
D2 and
now
you could go with Bishop D but the
problem is he moves the king and then
you cannot get in with your king you
need to save the D3 Square for your king
so you wait patiently
wait he pushes the G6 and it looks like
it's going to be a problem you again
patiently
wait he pushes again and suddenly you
play Bishop C4 and now what can he
do now it's very difficult for him
cuz if he pushes the G8 Pawn you take
that's not going to work so he goes
here King to E3 now
continue
yes
Julian correct Bishop D5 correct again
same problem we see here he can't move
the bishop away because if he moves it
what's going to happen yes remember
every time Bishop moves away A3 wins the
game so remember that you push it he
takes you win it and then you push A2
and A1 got it
excellent
G7 um yeah Bishop D5 now he went uh in
this this
position King
D3 yeah so King
D1 Bishop D5 he went here and the
winning move
is
yes K C2 King C2 Bishop moves
away
P push correct again if takes you play
B2 and you Queen okay
and if he plays Bishop F6 once again I
mean here both moves win but the the
strongest winning move
is A2 right absolutely push A2 very good
excellent so that's that's one
interesting position now I have another
example for you since we're on this
topic I would like to set up another
opposite color
Bishop this one also seems like draw is
in the reach you know it looks like
certainly draw is in the reach here here
but one move here basically one wrong
move and you can throw away the win and
in fact that's what happened in the game
stanovic wovi here white white made a
mistake here and threw away the win here
see you get a position like this you're
close to be winning as white because of
dominant bishop and a strong pass Pawn
but one mistake and guess what you just
threw away the win so that's why we're
studying this kind of end games so we
can understand the patterns to win this
position now in order to win this
position basically what we need to do
here who can tell me what we need to do
here to win this
position yes get the bishop out the way
get the bishop out of the way yeah but
it's not so easy to do that
it's actually if you reach the same
position with his turn you win did you
realize
that now think a little bit more after
that if you reach the same position with
his move you win this because he has to
move the
bishop he can't go to this squar he
moves away he go C7 C8 he moves his King
away you go C7 C8 as well
so you need to get
you need to lose a move
here and how do we lose a
moves absolutely normally if you want to
lose a move that is done by a method
called
triangulation okay player with the white
pieces just played casually casually
played this move and after his opponent
responded with
this became a
draw because here white king is getting
these six
square and now King D6 and he can never
win this position because he's got
that so how we going to get that
position here
Julian absolutely the winning move in
this position is King A7 but I think
King
A8 both moves winning King A8
now both moves winning so now he plays
Bishop C8 he leads to the same position
so here
here and now which move puts him into
that position yes King a absolutely King
A7 do not touch this pawn bishop from
here huh do not touch the bishop Bishop
must remain there and now you get this
position and looks like wait a minute he
has a huge scope now for this bishop
maybe he can go somewhere but in fact he
can't now if he moves away King here
push push you win if he goes here this
direction you go here and
again you simply push push and you win
the game got it that's the ideas simply
okay that's what you got to try to do
push push and you win so after you do
this it's just
hopeless so you will go King
B8 and
then you will win this
okay so remember not always it's a draw
if it's equal amount of pwns I mean most
of the time if it's equal amount of
Pawns opposite color Bishop it's very
likely to be a draw but there are
exceptions you know there are sukang
positions there there are many many
different positions where you still
remain winning
chances okay now the next position since
we're on this topic I would like to set
up the next position position here for
you to
see if you can figure
out the way to win
this why to
play you must make a decision
here you are under a check you go wrong
way you're not going to
win but which way we need to go here we
have a choice
here we have a choice here between King
E8 or King G8 but which one is the best
move and the one is going to help us to
win this game so let's think
here so we are under a check
here
you must see the winning plan Julian not
just a move winning plan you must
calculate because you know the decision
is huge here could cost a half Point
here basically if you go
wrong big decision here needs to be
made
okay
anybody I say you must calculate at
least five six moves here basically so
you can see that you have the the plan
the plan that is going to help you to
win
here what do you think huh
Julian
okay
you7
I offer you a
draw because I know you transferred my
Bishop from a long diagonal where I was
on here to the short fun but I'm still
I'm still remaining those I'm still
remaining those two squares here that
you cannot really get me out of it
okay so there is no way to win now
Julian because you
cannot get me
out so winning
[Laughter]
movies I guess now it's clear which one
is is the winning move
yeah who can explain why now King G8 is
the winning move
here do you see the difference now who
can see the difference yes
contr absolutely correct thinking yes
you control the f8 and G7 you were
controlling f8 earlier as well but you
controlling The crucial Square on
G7 and now no longer the bishop can
remain
there in the key line okay let's see
let's see the path to the victory here
Bishop C5 now
continue
Julian
yes yes Bop
a32 Bishop G7 I
take
yes it's very nice very nice yeah I was
thinking about Bishop C1 here but Bishop
h8 is another way to do it and the King
moves you put the bishop on G7 very good
yeah uh so you can also play the bishop
C1 move and if the bishop goes here you
simply play the winning
move
what is the winning move here the neat
move yes
B how about Bishop G5 this way you
completely take control of all the
squares yeah yes except
H6 okay so let's go back here so
everybody can understand here again you
see a position where maybe you feel like
uh you know both moves are winning but
in fact only
one and the correct one is King to G8
that's the only way to win it okay
because you need to control the crucial
G7 Square because when the bishop comes
to the short diagonal after you moveing
from the long one then you need to have
a control there okay so remember
that so check King
G8 you
wait and you go Bishop
f8 now it goes here
and same idea here actually you can just
play Bishop
B2 little shorter way to win because now
he can no longer go f8 you take here you
take he moves the king
simply when this
okay got it so that's the idea to
remember these are very important end
games to understand okay so okay next
one
okay interesting end game again it seems
like so close you know with this Pawn on
a seven and it almost feels like there
must be a way to win here it wouldn't
you know feel right you know if there's
no way to win this
but very difficult very trick actually
to find a way here you have to play this
precisely okay if you don't play this
precisely you're not going to be able to
win this
game okay any any anyone has ideas here
Julian well if you want to go there you
don't need to go Bishop A5 that's a
longer
route you can just use another
route okay well or Bishop H4
yeah the problem here is if I'm sitting
Julian's idea wins easily correct he
just goes
here simply exchanges the Bishops then
he promotes the pawn into a queen and
wins or if he moves the bishop away and
then you move this this is a winning
position because his Bishop is on a
really short diagonal I mean this is the
shortest it gets you know it doesn't get
shorter than this so then you just
simply go a decoy def flectional idea
Bishop G1 and you win the game got it he
cannot take because you
promote okay
so Bishop
A7
um but the problem here
is when you play Bishop H4 he sees your
idea if he doesn't C8 it's easy win he
goes King
to
B6 he goes King to B6 and he wants to
play King to
A6 now he wants to go King to
A6 well if you go check
he goes back and looks like nothing
really nothing really works at least for
now
okay so what do we do what can we do to
win
this
so I go here the first move is actually
correct B page four but remember uh we
might not succeed immediately putting
the bishop there but we might be able to
S succeed in getting the original
position with his move and if that
happens that will be a success
right so how can we do
that how can we do
that so we
check this is correct so
far this is correct so
far now only one move wins
it only one move not easy difficult one
but you know you have to kind of
play
this very precisely if you want to win
it
yes we came from
there we came from there yes Bishop
G1
mm Bishop G1 Bishop
G3 yes Bishop C5
correct Bishop C5 he cannot move the
King right because you go Bishop A7
Bishop B8 so he's going to wait right he
has to go here very important you go
Bishop C5 absolutely important so now he
goes here you'll see why at the
end
now we can go with a direct way to win
but now what do we
do we you need the bishop on C7 now
right to win this yes bishop7
correct now if he moves we just go
Bishop here and we win the game easy so
he goes back
here what do you
do check
here now which position did we reach
here do you see this one and you see
this one this is the original position
this is the original one and this is the
one we just
reach oh
sorry
okay you see the difference everybody
here see the difference everybody in
this
room what's the
difference yes Bishop on H Bishop is not
on H2 it's on G3 and that makes a whole
lot of a difference huge difference
because now what can you do to Win
It
you win it by gaining a crucial Tempo
here you win by gaining a crucial Tempo
yes Bishop H4 now attacking the bishop
Bishop cannot take Bishop with Queen the
pawn he goes Bishop
H2
Bishop
F2 Bishop
sits Bishop A7 he sits Bishop B8 he
moves away now you go back you thre to
Queen and if he goes here Bishop to here
you win the
game now why do I say Bishop C5 is very
important right because remember I
indicated that several times here why
Bishop uh is important so let's say you
do the same thing via Bishop to
D4 let's say you do via Bishop D4 guess
what not going to
work because he goes Bishop to D6 only
move only defensive move here now we
stay with the same program Bishop
here check here remember in other
position we attack attack and we got
here now we attack this
way guess what he goes here we don't
have this move here because he takes
it see that's why you had to go Bishop
C5 because that way when you go Bishop
C5
you stop him from putting his Bishop on
D6 you understand you prevented him from
putting his Bishop on
D6 that's why
okay that's the idea for you to remember
and now
simply Bishop B8 and win the
game okay everybody understand this
one so all we need to do is similar to
the other position is reach the same
exact position with black to move we do
that we're going to win
this next position we
have block to
play and
draw you are playing this position with
the black
pieces how you can try to draw this
game
there might be
uh there might be a way for you to tr
try to just uh wait until he pushes the
pawns and try to come up with a draw hit
but in a position like this there is a
very easy way to make a draw
here it's a very easy way because the
only way white can win this is by
advancing his
pawns okay by only advancing his pawns
he can win this there's no any other way
he can win it so what can we do here so
he
doesn't Advance them Julian G G4 risky
looking move here but that's the most
precise move here to make a draw because
what it does it simply fixes fixes the
structure that means he cannot push his
PS anymore because you simply fixed it
he cannot create a pass pawn and if he
pushes he can you can never win this
kind with this kind of Pawns you need
connected past pawns and those cases you
cannot win also but but without this you
can this is completely
draw okay so you go
G4 now opponent goes Bishop to D1
putting pressure continue Julian King
G5 don't be afraid to put your Pawn on a
collar of the bishop because he won't be
able really to attack it so he's going
to try to activate his King to try to
win it with
now you need to play this smart and put
your Bishop somewhere that whenever he
tries to get to activate the king you
start attacking that F2 Pawn there is
only one way to attack the F2 Pawn from
which
Square remember the question there's
only one square you can attack the F2
Pawn technically with so which square is
that
yes1 so where do you put the bishop
Bishop B4
absolutely King E2
and now Julian you wait you sit you wait
simply so if he goes King D3 as soon as
he tries to get active with this what do
you do Bishop E1 attacking on F2 he goes
back Bishop A5 that's how you do
it
okay now if he tries to push this
where do you put the bishop to put
pressure on the
target3 you can go to
C3 now he cannot push and now you want
to put a bishop on D4 to get more
centralization so he goes
here E1 correct again attacking this he
goes back here where the bishop
goes continue C3 now he goes here he's
trying to get you in a Suk
saang can he do that can he accomplish
that by putting you into Suk
saang so where do you do where do we go
with this bishop
yes he tries to get byass
you now we need to put the bishop
somewhere so we can attack this
yes Bishop C7 he tries to get
active
he tries to go
here calculate calculate the outcome
continue in the back
yes
yeah
huh2 Bishop takes F2 I
push
continue
Julian why pass Pawn take it take the
pawn he
push remember you got the bishop you got
the bishop covering this Square okay
even if you don't have that you can
still draw this because you could have
gone behind and check him here on
diagonal so he takes your pawn and you
put this King here to cement the draw
here okay because you know I say cement
because he cannot move it nothing can he
do to move your king from there okay so
that's how you hold this position
remember about fixing even you're behind
a lot of players they are afraid of this
idea when they play this kind of end gam
they're like so afraid of losing the
pawn but in fact the easiest way the
draw is achieved by fixing it okay you
fix the pawns that's the easiest way to
achieve it now changing the position
with white to move and trying to see
here if you can hold this who in this
room knows how to make a draw in this
position and confident he can draw this
against a
grandm this is a theoretically drawn
position but do you know how to achieve
it okay not so many people are confident
so let's see I guess I will show you in
detail here in detail how to make a draw
here it's very easy but you need to know
it okay if you don't know it and you
start guessing you could lose so King
goes on
F3 and for a moment it looks like it
might be a tough one because he's going
to get his connected pass pounds no
matter
what no problem you
sit so he goes King to
G4 you
sit so he plays
F4
you take okay we could have also played
Bishop B6 here maybe this is more
precise then he will go King to
E4 anyway he will play his plan
eventually so it's okay to allow him
this so you take now there are two ways
to
capture so the way it works is if you
know the defense you just it doesn't
matter for you which way he takes so if
he takes this
way you just attack this
Pawn so he's going to push off of course
and now we have
choice where do we put the bishop here
one move draws another move
loses yes Bishop E3 Bishop E3 see we
have three choices here we had from the
side from the back from the
front you choose to attack from the back
mm not the
best
yes why do you choose attack from the
front E5 I know but then he he runs out
of Pawns see this is the drawing Motif
because he runs out of uh pawns anymore
to win the game so so remember when
opponent has two connected pass Pawns in
opposite color Bishop you attack the
pawns from the front okay okay directly
Point your Bishop at it and attacking it
now you may think what about if he
Maneuvers it still not going to
work only two moves here that make a
draw only yeah only don't move the king
you move the king you lose you move the
bishop somewhere else you lose only only
this moves so you don't have that much
cushion here just have to be precise so
you
sit see he can't really move his King
away because his is hanging if he goes
here you cement nothing he can do here
he cannot push this anymore you have a
huge block on it and if you place here
G5 you take
it and it's a draw is
achieved okay now since you know how to
draw this I'm going to test you on the
other
capture okay see if I can try to trick
and
win okay what's the best way to hold
this
yes no no not somewhere in Precision
yeah if you're playing a game you're not
going to just put it anywhere you know
Precision Julian you end games that's
why you're learning this to be
precise one mistake and guess what you
just played five hours and you lose the
game that will not be
fun
huh
okay
check okay
okay one recommendation for you you
never move the king from the dark Square
okay when you defending these positions
don't move your king from the dark
Square keep it on a dark uh keep it on a
dark Square don't move on a light Square
that's not helping
you that's losing position King goes to
F5 G5 and you lose well you might still
make a draw but that's not a good way to
defend the best best way to defend is
you
sit you
sit sometimes in end games to make a
draw you just need to know how to just
wait okay wait now he goes here you see
it
again he goes here no problem let's
looks like he's making progress that's
fine so he
pushes now one wrong move and you lose
here what's the only move that will help
you to draw
here
I think Bishop
d uh idea is correct but more precise is
to go Bishop D6 because you kept the
pressure on the weakness so he checks
remember where do we go with the King G7
G7 only
move he
pushes and now where do we put the
bishop at attack from
the
front see I didn't put my king to a
light Square always remaining on the
dark squares okay and now you're
attacking the target if you place here
you block it okay if he goes here you
take
it okay that's the idea to remember okay
so see the King has to be on the same
color as the offici yeah
your
Bop yours yeah you know your Bish your
king stays on the color of your own
Bishop you have a dark Bishop stays on a
dark you have a light Bishop stays on a
light
clear okay all right everybody now know
how to hold
this okay let's test now let's test now
different position I'm changing the
position okay you had light Bishop now
it's it's going to be a different
Bishop this is a chance for you to
practice this
okay
okay I will be trying to win this as
white different Bishop different
structure okay I am going first
okay okay what's the best move for
black when he has three pawns you have
one Pawn what is the first thing we need
to do to achieve a draw um
f okay why do you do that um to separate
his and if he Dees it then he
can fix it I don't know if you want to
fix it here here it's a little bit
dangerous you lose it you want to
exchange it because look if in this case
you sacrifice your Bishop for two pawns
you lose because he'll still have one
Pawn remaining but if you exchange the
pawns and this sacrifice a bishop then
you'll win because then he he's not
going to be able to uh he's not going to
have anything basically clear clearcut
okay attack the weakness attack the
weakness and in right now there's no
weakness it's a strong unit we need to
exchange that unit to make it a little
bit weaker right at the moment it's a
strong unit no weakness okay I
continue
Julian
now one strong transfer one strong
transfer and draw is in the bag which
transfer I'm talking about
here you can achieve a draw different
ways but what is that
transfer yes Bishop C6 Bishop C6 C6
that's fine a move that's a fine move
you're giving me a little chance there
but it's still a draw
but there is a transfer that just simp
gives you the draw
Julian correct Bishop
E8 because now you want to go Bish P5
and attack this target so he's going to
sit you're going to attack so he can't
sit anymore he's going to push and as
soon as he pushes once again where do we
put the
bishop Bishop belongs
where
yes Bishop belongs where on the side or
front
front remember the front okay you're
defending these positions remember
Bishop belongs in the front Okay now I
wait only one move draws
now wrong move you lose see one move
draws here and that move is Bishop H7
remaining on that Diaga but luckily we
do have that square see if you allow me
to push this PS a little bit further
like for
example if
um see you may have the correct position
here right in a position like
this see he will go
here even though you have the the right
setup here but here you lose because you
run out of Moves Like here black runs
out of moves
here B yeah if you reverse the king and
Bishop that's actually still losing
we'll check that also yeah but in the
same exact pawns the pawns you got to be
careful because like this position you
have you know the right setup your
Bishop is in the front your king is
doing the right thing but the problem is
he just makes a waiting move with the
bishop and then we don't have a move
because black can now move this
check if you move the king he just
pushes so you go here check
check and now he goes
here
check he pushes it and now you got to
just go here and now he just simply
walks brings the King right here easy
way to win you just go
here this is not good he has to
stay and you push push and you win the
game
okay so that's that's the idea for you
to remember okay so you push push and
win the game using
the king uh your question Julian Julian
says if we reverse it might be a draw
but
unfortunately his pawns are already too
advanced here Julian okay and this
position he simply goes this
way so it's white to move let let's
assume he just goes here now he wants to
go King
F6 so you have to go here
correct
check
now attacking this guy
Bishop has to
move Bishop H5 King
F6 now G6 is coming
okay
check
now Bishop
moves then F7 and F6 see not every
position draw is reachable some
positions if you make a
mistake you can reach
it you can but oh this one you're right
actually this is a steel mate yeah very
nice but uh yeah we just we play it fast
that's why this happened
uh yeah just bring the bishop to H6 and
then do the same thing yeah so it only
happened because we we were not
focused yeah yeah
yeah okay so lot of Bishop end games
today okay lot of Bishop opposite color
same color Bishops so you see many
different uh Concepts okay that can
happen in the Bishops um is it uh pretty
clear what we covered today do anybody
has some questions maybe about opposite
color or so remember when you are down
two pounds don't think that you already
lost the game with opposite color you
still have chances to hold okay so don't
think about oh I'm already losing the
game because I'm down two PS no there
are still chances there are still
chances to hold in fact there are many
positions where you know you you you can
be down even
you know some positions you can be even
down three pounds you can still hold
like this one
here
see so you're down three pounds and it
just doesn't look like this is this
should be a draw
here but you you know you you if you're
blocking this pawns like that it's just
he can't really do anything so let's say
he tries to go this way
correct you just
wait or you can just wait like
this as soon as he goes here if you let
him play D6 you lose you can never allow
him to play the D6 ideas okay so it's
very important not to allow him to play
D6 actually probably the best the best
way is just to to keep the bishop uh
like
this
yeah or actually this was fine just go
here um okay Bishop here
here and looks like he's got you with a
sukang here with a king D4 but actually
he doesn't have you in suan Kish as long
as you don't play Bishop E5 check Bishop
E5 check King E3 he pushes F4 then you
lose the game you just simply wait
simply wait on that diagonal
yes G Bishop G3 or Bishop H2 both fine
then he goes
here so now he wants to push F4 what are
we going to do
Julian yeah so he gives you the
pawn we got to take it and guess which
position is
this
mhm mm Bish
P4
I think what you should do in this
position is you you you can even you you
would need to uh maybe give a
check now it goes
here and the question is if we if we are
in time here
because if he gets the pawns on F5 and
E5 we would need to have the bishop
already on G7 at that
time okay if we don't have a bishop
there then we're not going to be able to
have the right setup so let's say if we
have the setup this way see I don't
think we achieve a draw here because his
pawns are just coming in so sometimes
you have to be careful in a placement of
your Bishop if your Bishop doesn't reach
the square that you need to be you
actually can end up losing the game so
you would need to reach this position
the only way to make a draw here is to
have this bishop here okay or here this
is the only places where you can hold a
draw otherwise you're just going to be
in trouble okay so that's what you got
to try to do just have a bishop on G7 to
hold yes so so if you go back a couple
moves would you just go back to F6 in
that position
then uh here um you keep no here I think
it's it draw is still achievable it's
just I me after C5 so a couple mov
okay so King no actually here we're
we're making a mistake that's why we're
losing this actually what's the drawing
move
here so we take it Place F4 then it's
little problems how do you avoid that of
course you put the Blocker in check he
moves
away and thank you that's it any
questions that's how you do it okay okay
yeah so this is this is a draw because
you you have the King on the right
square and you have him guarded on this
diagonal this is a draw here there is no
way for him to win
this he can't really bypass you if he
goes this direction you just still
stay yeah you can there's no way for him
to you can even go
here because here you have a
check because here here now you come
back he attacks you attack he goes here
do not check see in Blitz many people
would check here you know they would
just play this and then lose but you go
here this is the holding move here
okay and if he goes here then you come
back he pushes here again and what's the
precise move to make a
draw B Bishop F4 check insert the check
he moves away then you take okay okay
very good so next lesson we will be
covering different end games could be
Rook end game or Knight end game but
today topic we spend a lot of time on
the Bishops okay opposite color Bishops
same color Bishops and different
patterns we saw that where you actually
quite often times you need to know how
to triangulate the position triangulate
the position or use a different method
to achieve the same position with
opponent's move in order to achieve a
draw okay so we saw several positions
like that so thank you everyone for
attending the class and I'll see you
next
[Music]
[Applause]
time